Jimmy Jimmy and Stephen all came back
last night doing the shows from their
home the only guy I saw a little bit of
was Jimmy Kimmel and he had like a three
camera shoot going on in his house
really it was very impressive I get a
ride him a note later JD says he watched
all three and he wants to critique and
offer opinion all three guys were
working under adversity they're doing
their show without a live audience and
they were doing it from their home by
the way this isn't just the three this
encompasses like I had there's a watch
what happens live there's uh there was
Conan he went back last night I want to
hear what you think
so the I'm going by who had the best
like backgrounds and the best sets and
also who had the worst connections the
best connections so who the host I had
the host and the guest the host the best
set was a sort of a tie it's a drumroll
please
I forget oh there it is close that had
the best sets give me Kimmel and Jimmy
Fallon because you sort of saw their
house I saw Jimmy Kimmel's and it was
gorgeous I mean that's some house he
lives in and then Jimmy found him what
which I didn't see him what is he well
you saw more of this house like you saw
there's one part where you saw like his
view from his living room so I thought I
was pretty interesting all right
worst set Stephen Colbert because it was
like a plain room with books the host
that had the best connection was Stephen
Colbert it was very crisp clean it was
bright it looked like he wasn't actually
on a set the worst connection however
was Jimmy Kimmel unfortunately what do
you mean connection I think it you know
he recorded it but like some other
studio taped it or whatever he like was
using his internet to shoot yes the
technical term Robert are you enjoying
JT's review I am I think I understand so
now on to the guests the best connection
Kim Kardashian was on Jimmy Fallon great
connection everything went smooth
are you and what room is this I'm in my
mom's glam room Kylie did my makeup in
my hair the worst connection I've seen
this is on multiple shows Jerry
O'Connell he was on Kelly and Ryan and
I'll watch what happens live both shows
were so pixelated and just like just
nothing was clear it looked very muddy
what's up guys are you I see I just want
to say to me me for a second a couple
weeks ago on Atlanta it was so funny
well you guys were having that dinner
you mean his connection isn't great it's
not that he's not a great guest thank
you saying I think you're saying that
his connection is so bad from his house
that it's hard to have him as a guest
yes when you do a review I have a cute
idea because you love fast food can you
give it a scale of one-to-five
filet-o-fish sandwiches when you read
the various categories like say I give
three like I did one fillet of fish to
there's one more category who had the
best like background or whatever I get
one by the way you aren't you you get
one filet-o-fish for your connection
you're dropping out what is the category
best set best whoever had the best
background for the guests Oh have they
any control of that do they the guest
himself puts the camera where he wants
to yes correct
so the best background I know what
Tracy's had to be shocked he has a shark
too yes he has uh like an aquarium that
he built no it was actually his book his
bowling alley
he had like his bowling alley back here
he had like some like video game thing
that was like flashings it was very
interesting to watch the worst
backgrounds and this is purely because
you wanted to see like his house and
stuff Adam Sandler he was on Conan and
he was like like he look like he was
like a bedroom closet it wasn't a whole
lot going on back there so how many
filet-o-fish do you give Adams
I will give I have sailor to flail
fishes for his background and I'll give
you a fish I'll give one plural of fish
do you know the plural of fish flail
fishes Oh fish lays filet-o-fish there
you go I love you so much
fillets oh fish alright so on how many
fillets or fishes you say do you give to
Tracy Morgan Tracy Tracy Morgan is five
five fillets Oh fish how about five
fillets Oh fishes can I give you five
filets Oh fishes for your excellent two
segments here if you like sure tell me
what your sister JD though let's let you
know that's why I showed up today I mean
you're all wondering why I crashed your
party because I started getting tweet
saying JD is trashing your show what
Andy Andy we will be quiet
I'll let you talk to JD JD go ahead
you're on with Andy I'm sorry go ahead
you've been trying to do a show I'm it's
like hanging on by a piece of scotch
tape I mean if my show was low-tech
before it was my first show back I mean
we're at the mercy of people's Wi-Fi
connections and then I get a tweet I'm
like man and I kept tweeting last night
I was like you guys forgive us it's a
little janky but what was the thing by
the way JD your home is a little nicer
than I expected
oh thank you first of all I'm glad
you're feeling better I like you I was
not [ __ ] on the show like you two
you're going off social media which is
never good correct all these [ __ ] on
Jerry O'Connell's internet connection I
saw it was terrible okay by the way I
have to interrupt this conversation JD's
reviews of late night television are
already shaking up Hollywood as you can
see
Andy Cohen on his deathbed had to call
in because he was unhappy about JD's
review